e
no uh Cherry is probably going to be
here she's been sending me notices and
we've been we've been back and
forth
morning we are in a little bit of a
flurry making sure we have a full
Corum two four five six seven eight
since we don't I will uh mention a
couple of the bills that I'm working on
for next year that I would appreciate
co-sponsors
for uh the first first two are about
General
regulation and cleanup language for
oplc um anyone who's interested let me
know I'll be glad to add you there's
another one on for the retirement system
to eliminate the Restriction of one year
of workers comp applying to your
um um toward your pension that came up
when we had the severely injured
policeman who said well I would have
reached 10 years but I only got credit
for one year of being out on workers
comp when was actually more like a year
and a half so I Mr D yes yes and so I
thought that there I can't think of any
particular reason why if someone is out
on workers's comp he shouldn't be
included in the pension system for as
long as it takes for him to recover so
if you're interested in that let me know
and I'll be glad to add it I'm
interested you're in okay
good and now look at the
language as well all right I will uh
make a note of that you can put on oh
yes please I think it should be uh a few
more all right thank you I thought that
one would be more
popular all right then there's um on
Municipal enforcement of building and
fire codes which was a request of the
building uh building code review
board and then there's a student license
for Respiratory
therapists who are able to start working
on on some parts of their job before
they get their full training and their
full
license and so this would let them be
employed on what they what they have
already
learned um before before they finish
their
training so a minor
one anyone
else
three all
right all right thank you to the new
members for the day at least we have 10
quum so I'm opening the executive
session on our retained bills and I want
to start with House Bill
1676 which is a sunet commission
representative
broa thank you Madame chair um House
Bill
1676 um had to do with the sunsetting
Comm of of uh o of um boards and
commissions within
oplc and the committee I I think the
committee's position I believe I'd like
to discuss that is that since the
introduction of this bill was made last
year there's been a lot of changes that
have taking place in the office of
professional LIC Insurance
certification and I think that before we
look at changing boards and sunsetting
some and and
uh sunsetting boards and commissions we
should give the organization time
to to orient itself and um
have
the before further actions is taken on
any kind of board structure so at this
time I don't think we we should be
recommending any further legislation in
this
area that would be my
discussion
represent the Motions at least seconds
I'm I've never been uh never had a
definitive
ruling
um oh that's fine we'll uh I I'm not
sure it it matters my uh I'd like to say
on this is that a sunset commission is a
good idea
to go back and look at what we're doing
and decide if we still need to do it
because there's an awful lot of our laws
that haven't been changed in 50
years
and but on the other hand an
organized review like the sunset
commission needs to be supported
and so far neither of the candidates for
Governor has shown any interest in in
doing anything of the sort so I'm not
sure I would want to try and impose it
at this this
else okay in that case the motion is no
further not recommended for further
legislation and the clerk can call the
we have 10 at the moment but another one
tell whoever you get to show up when
they
you okay got everybody all right vote
roll
representative Simon yes representative
Dolan clerk vot yes representative Boyd
yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Bolton yes representative
yes and the chair
yes T zer all right is if there is there
any objections to consent if we have
one nope not seeing any we'll put that
right representative uh Shu do you have
a motion on House Bill
1324 yes Madam chair I do um I'll be
recommending to not go
forward um reason being that um this
committee actually put the bill into
subcommittee and we heard quite a bit of
testimony both at the hearing which was
quite lengthy and at the
subcommittee and then we decided to put
it into interim study because there were
still many questions about the bill that
were
unanswered we basically put to the
sponsors uh to reach out to the funeral
directors uh first I guess I should say
that this this was dealing with um the
idea of natural organic red reduction of
human remains and we heard questions
from the Funeral Directors
Association and the cemetery
Association and also from the dicese of
Manchester of the Catholic church and we
basically asked asked the sponsors to
reach out to the funeral directors and
the cemetery Association to see if they
could work out any kind of compromise
between what they were saying and what
these two groups were saying they saw as
concerns with the
bill um I reached out last week to Mr
Moren uh who represented the funeral
directors and to uh the gentleman who
represented the cemetery
associations and I even checked with uh
the cemetery committee from my own town
uh the sponsors had not reached out to
these
folks they did purport that I guess
seven states in the US have adopted this
policy uh the one that I could find that
had adopted rules was the state of
Washington and part of their rules
mandated that um
these remains had to
be uh collected if no one claimed them
had to be collected in a container or
many sealed
containers uh they also
um do advocate for alkaline hydrolysis
in Washington which we do not and they
put this under that statute according to
Mr Moren the Funeral Directors
Association met with um the state of
Vermont who has adopted the policy they
adopted it two years ago and still have
not uh been able to craft rules dealing
with it and the main objection with this
large amount of remains we heard that it
could be as much as a pickup
loadful uh so that's a lot of material
to deal with
and um my point also was that all of our
Municipal
cemeteries would have to adopt some kind
of ordinance changes to accommodate
these kinds of Barrels in their
facilities So based on the fact that
there have been no uh real resolution to
these
concerns uh I'm recommending not to go
forward with this legislation
all
questions I I Rec agree with
representative Shou that we don't need
to go forward with this right now it's
still
legal for some for a family
to to bury someone on their own land
with with or without any kind
of EMB bombing or or caskets or whatever
at their choice as long as they just
notify the town clerk that there is a be
a body there and with that in mind and
there are natural cemeteries where the
same thing can happen so I don't see the
need for
this accelerated process be and at least
until they can res solve the issue of
um having large quantities of of residue
that need to be dealt with and it needs
to be dealt with in a respectful manner
so I'm I strongly agree we shouldn't go
forward with this
bill anyone
else
okay in that case Welcome to our new
member this
is and representative Walsh Rockingham
15 okay
and for uh Lyn Bailey representative
Bailey who has not shown up or actually
for probably for representative laus who
town all
right any other comments question
representative
Schmid thank you madam chair so I I I
think there I agree with repes represent
Shu that there are a number of issues
that are
unresolved uh but that since there
clearly
are movements within the the whole
industry with regard to looking at these
Alternatives and so forth and the
sponsors here um uh so I I think I think
it needs to have a natural Evolution
rather than being force-fed so to speak
by by the legislature at this point in
my opinion so I'm I'm okay since this
doesn't bind anybody the sponsor can
bring it back on her own if she so
chooses um but I'm okay with not
recommending it but on the part of the
else okay in that case the motion is not
recommended for further legislation and
the clerk can call the role represent
Simon yes
represent
Walsh yes represent Dolan yes clerk vote
Yes represent Boyd yes represent
groa yes represent Schmidt yes represent
Bolton yes representative Shu yes
representative Howard
yes and we got 11 y Zer n oh and the
chair I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry for
that I should V we' been out for a while
so I
apologize thank you representative yes I
vote Yes you had such a compelling um I
like what you said so fine
okay any objections to
consent okay seeing none we'll do
consent
thought representative Brown is not able
to be here and he has told told me he
recommends not
going he is not recommending for further
legislation House Bill
1420 that's Communications between
agencies and
citizens is there a
second a second okay the the reason is
that that is an excellent idea that the
agency should be responsive to the
citizens answer the their phone calls
replied to their letters and all that
however his bill as written is
unenforceable and if we tried to enforce
it we would have we would be in a
nightmare of keeping track of phone
calls and when the responses were and
how the calls got routed if somebody
called and didn't know exactly who to
speak
to um
it's we think that's something that the
managers of each agency should be
responsible
for and we'll keep an eye on it but it
it's not recommended for legislation as
such and so I'm that's what the
recommendation
is anyone else represent schm no oh okay
anyone
else I just want to make sure I I I just
want the rest the the the newer members
of the committee to um realize that the
request was that they had to respond
within three business
days which was in some
cases difficult if every single call had
to be handled that way so since there
was no priorities or
or uh description further than that that
was the issue as well
yes and and of course there are always
cas of well
you Mr Brown knows all the answers and
he'll be glad to talk to you as soon as
he gets back from his Hospital stay or
his uh or his vacation or whatever
there's there was no
flexibility and keeping track of it to
make sure that it happened would be a
nightmare I I don't think it's workable
I just
exactly all right so anyone
else those in favor uh the clerk can
call the role thank
you to be
for represent Simon yes representative
Walsh yes representative Dolan yes clerk
votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Bolton
yes representative Shu yes
representative Howard yes and the chair
110 the motion passes any objections to
consent okay representative
one thank you madam chair I would like
to move uh no uh no future or no further
uh legislation on HB 1653
call
second 1653 yes here to speak on it uh
sure so um this bill uh is one of many
bills that we've heard over the last
couple years um pertaining to um
benefits uh retirement benefits for
group two
employees especially those who um
commenced work prior to July 1st 2011
but hadn't been vested by 200 uh
whatever it was 12 uh 12
um and uh a lot of work has gone into it
uh this year we were able to pass into
law hb1 1647 which addresses um the
content of this bill and so um further
consideration I think would be
unworkable Pro potentially redundant um
since this has already become law and
all of the parties that were involved
seem to be okay with the way things
turned out so um for those reasons I'll
say that we probably shouldn't be
pushing for further legislation at this
time
representive brto the committee received
three similar bills and the one that we
chose to go forward with was
1647 and so since that one was the the
vehicle by which we had a tremendous
amount of negotiations within the house
and then within the Senate um we really
I I know that at this time any other uh
retirement bills that are similar to
that should not be
entertained so I agree okay anyone else
discussion okay that case the motion is
not recommended for further legislation
and the clerk can call the
role represent Simon yes representative
Walsh yes representative Dolan yes clerk
votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative
gr yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Bolton yes representative
shu yes representative of Howard yes and
the chair yes 11 y z n all right
objections to
consent seeing
none all right representative Simon
1673 thank you madam chair I'd also like
to move no no recommendation for further
legislation on 1673 uh for all the
reasons just stated on 1653 that's the
same
scenario I'll second that one
also
any discussion on this similar but not
identical
Bill okay in that case the clerk can
role represent Simon yes representative
Walsh
yes represent
Dolan clerk votes yes representative
voyd yes
representative groa yes representative
yes representative Howard yes oh I'm
sorry representative Shu thank you yes I
apologize representative Howard
yes
l0 in the chair chair I'm sorry in the
11 it's all right clerks are notorious
for skipping the chairs it's cuz they
put you on the top where you belong but
I'm reading downward
uhuh anyway the uh Mo the motion passes
110 any objections to
consent okay we'll try for
consent
okay hoping representative gold would be
here representative bro did you have
another rep motion
um I have a motion for House Bill 1689
relative to the use of personal
identification information by state
agencies okay and we recommend no no uh
no further legislation on this I'll
explain to you the committee we are all
concerned with the privacy of
identification information within state
agencies I think it's something that we
should be all on our radar but we are
also concerned that this bill
particularly conflict with the
legislative requirements that we placed
on agencies such as the Department of
Health and Human Services and we feel
that well I was thinking my
recommendation be that the committee
feels that before further legislation
put forward the nature of this
legislation on agencies on agencies as
well analyzed and understood by the
bills um is there a second I'll second
okay thank
you comments
pres Bolton you're free to speak if you
like sure thank you madam chair and um I
would agree that this bill needs to be
reworked um I intend to go forward with
a another bill this next year and I
would appreciate um ultimately when this
bill we discuss the bill and vote on it
but um I would like to have any sponsors
to be on on the bill so that we can do
I strongly support that sentiment that
we should get the bills right before
submitting
them any other
comments all right cler can call the
rooll representative Simon yes
representative Walsh yes representative
Dolan clerk votes yes representative voy
yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative y representative Shu yes
representative Howard yes and the chair
okay it's that passes 11 to zero any
objection to
consent okay we will try
consent
yes
ENT
certainly you
okay hi um I would like to make a motion
of uh on House Bill 1333 which is
relative to the prohibition of state
agencies from buying or leasing electric
fleet vehicles for 10
years so all uh and my my recommendation
will be that no further legislation is
taken on this
um so there is a concern by some that
and by many on electric vehicles however
I think that state
agencies prohibiting state agencies from
making their own decisions on this kind
of matter is not the in the purview of
the legislature and also to come up with
a number of 10 years it seems also
random so for these two reasons I don't
think that we should that this type of
legislation should not be
entertained in the next
session all right it does is there a
second
second by representative
Schmid okay any other comments
representative
Simon thank you madam chair I know that
uh electric vehicles sometimes get
caught up in the Whirlwind of debate
over climate change uh issues um but I
agree with with representative gerto
that I don't think any further um
legislation should be recommended at
this time simply for the fact that we
have absolutely no idea what kind of
innovation will take place over the next
10 years uh I know that the prime
sponsors of the bill um mentioned things
such as our electrical grid and capacity
um but we don't know whether or not the
capacity required to charge these
vehicles over the next 10 years is going
to decline rapidly um expense might
decline rapidly and I know there were
safety concerns over battery use um but
those also might stabilize over the next
10 years and so we don't want to
handicap our agencies from being able to
make those kind of decisions at those
times I think um all of our jobs in the
government is to make the um best
decisions that we can with the
information that we have in the moment
um and so I I assume that's what we'll
do now and also over the course of the
next 10 years so I just don't want to
hamstring anybody from uh by being too
shortsighted in in the
moment and I'd like to add that this
year we also created a commission of
various stakeholders to consider the
safety and cost effectiveness of
electrical cars and they're working on
it I wouldn't want
to Short Circuit their deliberations by
saying we can't buy any cuz I'm I'm sure
there are some some situations where
electrical vehicles are appropriate in
state fleets and they and I trust the
agencies to figure it out for
themselves anyone
else representative Schmid I mean these
last two remarks are especially uh the
millstone around the neck of this
proposal you know to try to tie hands
for 10 years completely unwise something
that's developing as rapidly as AVS are
and chair's remarks are equally
appropriate so we're going in the right
direction thank you anyone
else okay the clerk can call the rule
the motion is not recommended for
further legislation represent Simon yes
represent Walsh yes represent Dolan yes
clerk votes yes represent Boyd yes
represent groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Bolton yes
representative Shu yes representative
Howard yes and the chair yes 11 y z and
a all
right 11 to zero is any objections to
consent seeing none we'll do that if
there is one all right what do we got
here I was expecting representative gold
to be here but in her place I will move
house bill
1679 Atlantic time to not recommended
for further
second second
okay
and the point of this is that New
Hampshire is a very small
state we don't really want to be out of
sync with our
neighbors what we we need a federal or
at least a Regional approach to time we
and so until and unless Congress
Acts or even better than that you know
all the New England
states we don't want we need to be with
our neighbors on time it's it's
ridiculous to think that we would have
our a separate time zone and
um uh I don't think we should waste our
legislator's time
in trying to deal with this again
however nice it would be because we're
not going to go alone on this
one anyone else
dito thank you
any all right in that case the clerk can
role represent Simon yes represent Walsh
yes representative Dolan yes cler votes
yes representative Boyd yes represent gr
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Bolton yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes and
the chair yes 11 y z n all right 11 to
zero any objections to
consent okay seeing
none all right now the messy ones House
Bill 1271 representative gr do you have
a
motion thank you um Madam chair for
reasons that I stated earlier on House
Bill let me see if I can remember that
pH um house bills
1676 I recommend that we don't further
review the um conversion combination of
reorganization of boards and advisory
boards furthermore we took the parts of
this bill you might might well some of
you will not know this but this
committee had um retained House Bill 12
71 and during the course of the Year
during the session we um attached the
parts that the
committee had not objected to onto
another bill which the governor vetoed
and we could not override the vetto last
week so um and it included the
combination of some of the boards since
then we've learned that some of the
individuals on for example the
acupuncture an Asian art board did not
want to be an Advisory Board and also
um so I'm recommending that we don't we
just start a new and we don't
particularly reintroduce this bill next
year okay is there a
Schmidt okay any repres Schmid do you
comment my comment is no
comment thank
else okay if no one wants to represent
comment okay that's no so the motion is
not recommended for further
legislation and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative Walsh yes representative
Dolan yes clerk vote Yes representative
Boyd yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Bolton yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes and
the chair yes 11 y0
n okay motion passes any objection to
consent okay all right the last one my
God we're moving right along is House
Bill 1408 reorganization of various
boards
and on the advice of Representative gold
I'm going to move that it is recommended
for further legislation
on one specific
Foresters has a requirement for a public
member that is not involved in the
forestry business and they have a great
deal of trouble filling that board
filling that position and they would
like to have another land owner or
Timber owner on the board so she is
recommending that
we uh move that forward because the
board composition is specified in
law and
so uh I will make that motion on her
behalf is there a
second
okay does anyone have a comment question
or
discussion I do have a comment because
and I I'll I'll support the um the
recommendation
but it seems to me that there would be
many
more non Foresters in New Hampshire than
Foresters so I'm surprised that that
position is difficult to fill and why do
we have non we do oftentimes have public
members that are not related to the
field itself for nonbiased for biased
reasons so um I just would be more I
I'll be those are the types of things
I'll be interested in knowing if the
legislation is brought
forward that I'm trust we will give it
scrutiny all right any other comments
questions okay that case the clerk can
call the
role represent Simon yes representative
Walsh yes representative Dolan yes CL
votes yes representative void yes yes
representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Bolton yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes and
the chair yes 11 y0 a okay any
objections to
consent all right seeing none we will
put this on consent or try to put all of
them on
consent and that finishes our work for
the session thank you all for coming and
thank you for those who were able to uh
support
us all them yes all right thank you
thank you all we are uh in case this
audition was uh to your liking we're
going to have uh lots of vacancies for
next term so keep us in mind thank you
for that advertisement representation we
will have
vacancies okay
uh reports are
due immediately or as soon as let's see
you have two I have
two R gr has three rent Shu has
one
and actually gr has four I think one
two yeah I have two gr has
do and thank you all for coming sorry we